welcome to the show friends neighbors
comrades today is my new book Church of
cowards which you can see displayed very
tactfully and and subtly beside me is
finally released and I want to talk
about why I wrote it and what problem I
I hope it addresses also the issue of
student loan debt is center stage in
many ways this campaign sees I think
it's be one of the central issues of the
2020 election and it's central to the
rise of Bernie Sanders so I want to
discuss that and specifically one of the
biggest villains in the story of student
debt one group that is among the most
responsible for driving the crisis yet
has escaped somehow for the most part
the public's wrath so I want to draw
attention to that group and talk about
that also we'll do a roundup of five
other news headlines worth knowing about
and a surprising person today must be
canceled on the show I have to cancel
someone who I bring me no joy at all to
cancel them but I must do it and we'll
get to all of that coming up but first
let's check with ancestry DNA you know
there are many paths to finding your
family story whichever way you choose
tracing our family generation
generations back with a family tree or
uncovering your ethnicity with ancestry
DNA it's easy to get started with
ancestry that's one of the things I want
to highlight is just how easy this is to
do I know when I did it it seemed kind
of daunting at first I thought it would
be a whole complicated process it's
really not it's very quick and easy to
do and then you know ancestry DNA it
tells you where your ancestors are from
and also billions of records and
millions of family trees let you
discover their personal stories so it's
not just about the geographic locations
although that's very interesting part of
this it's also about their stories and
and and who they wore and what they were
like so you could find out you have an
infamous relative or you could you know
find a photo of your
great-great-grandmother
as a little girl many many possibilities
whatever you find it's sure to change
the whole way you look at your family
history and also yourself ancestry DNA
can reveal ethnic origins that can
provide historical details that bring
unique family stories to life and that
was my experience with it as I said
a very easy process and it's just been
fascinating to see kind of discover more
about who I am and what I've discovered
is that and I think this is what
everyone finds out is that your family
history is much more interesting and
complicated and diverse than you ever
expected that certainly has been my
experience so you could start exploring
your family story today head to my URL
at ancestry.com slash Matt to get your
ancestry DNA kit and start your free
trial
that's ancestry.com slash met
ancestry.com slash Matt okay my book
Church of cowards released today that is
my my second book and I can tell you
that after two books I very much relate
to I think it was a quote from Dorothy
Parker originally who said I hate
writing but I love having written and
that's very much my feeling on the day
of a book release it's a feeling of I'm
so glad that's over and to be perfectly
honest with you this book I found
especially difficult to write in some
ways and the reason is that it's it's an
emotionally draining topic one that I
think we all may prefer at times to turn
away from and ignore but we can't as
Christians we can't do that we have to
face it and that's why I wrote the book
and I hope you'll go to Amazon and buy
it or you know if you're old fashioned
you can go to an actual book store and
pick up a physical copy there and buy it
that way as well
now I call this book a church of cowards
a wake-up call to complacent Christians
because I believe that cowardice and
complacency is the cancer the poison
that has seeped into the church in
America now you compare our situation to
that of Christians and so many other
parts of the world especially in the
Middle East parts of Africa parts of
Asia particularly North Korea places
like that
in those regions Christians are directly
violently blood aliy persecuted killed
martyred thrown into concentration camps
and in a place like North Korea and yet
yet the faith itself for those who
remain alive and and free the faith is
vibrant and strong and surviving persist
thing Christians in those countries
really believe it seems here though you
know we're under no real threat of
violence no threat of that kind of
direct violent persecution you can go to
church on Sunday with minimal concern
perhaps not no concern but minimal that
that your physical safety and the safety
of your family will be will be in
jeopardy and you can live your life as a
Christian go about your day generally
speaking proclaim your faith you could
shout it from the rooftop if you want
and for the most part the most you're
gonna face at worst is snide remarks
maybe from from strangers insults maybe
some frowny face emojis will be tossed
in your direction on Facebook and yet in
this country people are leaving the
faith in droves our the the situation is
worse really then the statistics would
show because if you look at the
statistics you'll find that the
percentage of Christians has dropped
over the years but it will say depending
on what you where you look it'll say
that they're what 80 percent 80 percent
or something of the American population
is still Christian well that's a smaller
number than than it was before but but
even that number I think we all know is
not accurate it's not really 80 percent
not really eighty percent of people who
are truly believing Christians on fire
with the faith right but if you do look
at the polls in the surveys and I cite a
number of them in the book you see that
increasing numbers of Christians are
denying basic doctrinal tenants of
Christianity we see that our children
the younger generation they're not
remaining in the faith they're leaving
oftentimes around the around college age
now why should we in our comfort in our
luxury be falling apart as a church
while the Christian communities that
have every external reason to fall apart
or not well I think it comes down to
complacency we're sort of drifting along
we don't have to think much
about our faith about religion about our
mortality we don't have to make
sacrifices you know Christ says pick up
your cross and and follow me but we feel
like we don't have to why should we
because life is comfortable life is
supposed to be comfortable we believe
and you know I'd rather just I'd rather
leave the the cross outside go inside
and watch Netflix or something and so
there's a spiritual atrophy that happens
now many leaders of the church will not
jolt people out of this stupor they're
not going to call their flocks to deeper
and more authentic faith and I'm going
to call their flocks to repentance
because they don't want to scare people
they don't want to upset anybody they
don't want to run against the cultural
glint grain they're cowards but their
cowardice doesn't pay off on any level
really because what they find is that
their reluctance to challenge the people
that are sitting in the pews only leads
to those people being people being bored
to death and deciding that there's
really no reason for them to go to
church or to remain active in the faith
or to pay attention to Christianity at
all
if this is all it has to offer there's a
reason why the conservative and Orthodox
churches tend to be younger more vibrant
bigger healthier more energetic because
those churches give people a reason to
come right they give people an
experience
that is distinct from the culture the an
experience that has a purpose a
direction but of course if you take your
church in that direction there's going
to be there might be initially a purge
that happens first there's gonna be
growing pains where first the lukewarm
Christians who are in the pews are
scared away so you're gonna lose those
people before you gain more you're gonna
lose those people and that's okay
because it's better for lukewarm
Christians to run away to leave to
confront who they are and what they
really believe for their own sake as I
say that we say is eighty percent of
Christians in this country I don't know
what the real number is it's not 80
percent what is it ten percent 25
percent I'm not sure that's a thing
nobody knows but it would be right
be better to get down to that core so we
know where we stand as a church and then
we can build from there now I go into
detail about these issues in the book I
also offer what I think is the
prescription part of a solution and that
takes me many pages to explain so you
have to read it but I will say that it
begins with I think us as as Christians
calling each other and calling ourselves
to a faith that is active that is live
that's authentic that's distinct that's
noticeable to the outside world because
to believe and I have a whole chapter on
this in the book to believe in in Jesus
you know part of the problem is we I
think we have our concept of what that
even means in the West is is very
superficial I think to believe in Jesus
is not just an intellectual proposition
it's not it's not merely in a sent to a
a fact it's not just saying yes Jesus is
God I agree with that statement
that's not faith that's that's agreement
that's acknowledgment is that all we're
meant to do is just acknowledge
something inside sure yeah yeah okay
yeah I believe that yeah okay fine I
think faith is lived faith is something
that we do it's a it's a it's a an act
it's like love you know you love your
spouse and I think we would all agree we
say we love our spouses it's not merely
something we feel even less is it a fact
that we acknowledge yes we acknowledge
them we know they exist but that's not
what loving them means it's something
that we do it's a sacrifice that we make
it's a daily task and the doing the
acting the living it's not that you
prove your love that way that's not that
that's not what it is it's that you love
that way that's how you do it that's
what love is and I think love for God is
the same faith is the same it's not
something that you can entirely do while
lying on your couch covered in Cheetos
dust at all hours of the day so
this is a call to an active lived public
faith and that's really just the
beginning of it I talk in the book also
about the concept of repentance I talk
about as Christians our interaction with
the culture and the need to balance
being in the culture with protecting
ourselves from its temptations I talked
about you know the reality of evil I
talked about virtue false virtues that
are often sold in the modern church
versus real virtues and many other
things as well
Church of cowards go buy it right now I
demand okay so next we're gonna discuss
student loans and as I said the villain
in the story that often escapes our
wrath but first let's run through a
little lightning round of other
headlines worth knowing about to get you
up to speed number one we got 5 stories
here at number one at a town hall
yesterday Bernie Sanders was asked about
the fact that he's an old geezer a
person in the audience wanted to know if
he's gonna pick a running-mate because
you know he's gonna die soon but it
wasn't directly said but that's of
course the the implications and Bernie
had an interesting response this is what
he said and yes the answer is we will do
that but it's a little bit presumptuous
right now I will tell you one thing
though you know is that person will not
be an old white guy that I could say
defendant ago okay now here's here's
here's a question nobody in the media
will ever ask hey Bernie if you have a
problem with old white guys and you
think old white guys shouldn't be in
power then why don't you an old white
guy drop out and throw your support
behind someone who is not an old white
guy I mean how do you an old white guy
justify trying to prevent a woman or a
younger person or a minority from
becoming president because that's what
you're doing you right now Bernie
Sanders you say I'm not gonna have an
old white vice president okay but you
are right now actively trying to prevent
a woman from becoming president may
Elizabeth Warren's a woman and she even
has all the same ideas you do you're
trying to prevent her how do you explain
that
but of course that question will never
be asked precisely because there's no
good answer that Bernie could provide
and so the media is not going to ask him
number two a website called the recount
com has put together an interesting
compilation which which which seems to
give more ammunition to those who claim
that Pete Budaj is trying to be the
white Obama look at this the person who
got the most votes gusta thought brings
us PES as confessed country was built to
answer that call now when Pete releases
his birth certificate to prove that he
wasn't born in Kenya then we're really
going to know that this is a copycat
situation number three Harvey Harvey
Weinstein has been found guilty on two
counts rape and a criminal sex act so he
faces five to twenty nine years in
prison now I've seen some media people
congratulating themselves for all the
good work the media did in exposing
Harvey Weinstein this is the the level
of self-awareness that the media has
they were the ones who refused to report
on Weinstein's predatory behavior for
decades literally decades remember there
was an open secret
everybody knew so he's going to jail now
but he should have went to jail years
and years ago and if he had there there
are many women who were victimized who
would not have been Hollywood protected
him the media protected him let's not
forget that number four Pixar has a new
movie coming out this one is called
onward comes out I think this weekend
maybe next weekend it's about from what
I can tell from a previous it's about
two trolls who have to bring their dad's
legs to a magical wizard or something so
that they can retrieve his torso and the
rest of him is actually the plot of the
movie or something like that
it's unique at least I'll give them that
but Pixar is here's the not so unique
part they're really going for the woke
points on this one because this film
will feature Pixar's first
ever lesbian there's gonna be a lesbian
character and we're told that her
lesbianism will be made explicitly clear
hopefully not too explicit this is a
kids movie after all but you never know
these days I will never understand this
idea this claim that there aren't enough
gay characters and movies and on TV so
we have to keep adding them in and every
time we do there's cause for celebration
you know it seems to me based on my own
anecdotal experience for what I've seen
there's a gay character on almost every
TV show now and every year there are
movies about gay love affairs that are
getting awards and so on and so on so
how much of this do we need before we
can say that gay people are represented
is it is it is it enough yet can we
officially say they've been represented
or do we need I'm just what exactly is
that is the quota we're shooting for
that's my only question finally five
scientists have discovered the first
known animal that doesn't breathe which
which I find very interesting it has no
respiratory genes at all which sets us
apart sets it apart from every other
multicellular organism that we're aware
of this creature is according to live
science calm a gelatinous parasitic blob
so anyway I'm surprised to find out that
Michael Moore doesn't have lungs it's um
that was a cheap shot
but honestly his name was the first one
that popped into my head when I read you
lad and his parasitic blob it's not my
fault and no offense and tendons
but that's just the first thing that
popped into my head all right now I want
to talk about as I said this is student
loan issue there are many villains in
the story of the student debt bubble the
universities that charge exorbitant
tuition rates simply because they can
bilking working families out of
thousands of dollars for an education
that isn't worth even a fraction of that
cost they should be first in line to
absorb the blame and it seems like
somehow they're not at least when you
listen to something like Bernie Sanders
talk about it he's not pointing so much
to the universities themselves because
you know on the far left you don't want
to upset academia because we want to
teach art to trust academia so but I
think they're first in line I'd blame
them first but it's a long line indeed
the government has earned a hefty
portion of our collective scorn for
issuing these predatory loans to kids
fresh out of high school with no assets
no income and then blame goes to the
public schools who are funneling kids
into the university system
indiscriminately regardless of an
individual kids aptitudes and skill set
just pushing them all into to colleges
parents as well are adding to the
pressure which I'm convinced for many
parents pressuring their kids in the
four-year institution it has as much to
do with with the the parents own vanity
as it does their concern for their for
their child I'm not saying they're not
concerned for that child but I think
part of it at least is that the parent
wants to be able to say my kid is going
to such-and-such school parent doesn't
want to say my kids not in college but
there's another group so we can thank
all of those people for the 1.5 trillion
dollars in student debt there's another
group though that seems to have largely
somehow escaped the public's wrath
despite their unique role in driving
this problem and that would be employers
we take it for granted that our kids
need quote unquote to obtain a college
degree because so many jobs require them
but the need is artificial in the vast
majority of cases thousands of employers
across the country have chosen to
artificially inflate their job
requirements often demanding that
applicants have have-have degrees for
positions that absolutely do not really
necessitate them
and they've chosen to do this and it's
only getting worse
you know positions that didn't require
any degree 20 years ago now require a
bachelor's degree and positions that
required a bachelor's degree 20 years
ago now require a master's and you know
before you know it you're gonna need to
have a PhD to be a sales associate at JC
Penney this again is is artificial
people without degrees could perform the
tasks necessary for most of these
positions but employers disqualify them
from consideration right out of the gate
and for no good reason now obviously and
every time I talk about this there I
hear from people saying what about
doctors and lawyers and yes obviously
some jobs do require additional formal
schooling but not every job does and not
even most jobs nobody is suggesting that
a guy with a high school diploma should
be hired right off the street by Johns
Hopkins to perform brain surgery no one
is suggesting that but most jobs outside
of science and medicine have to be
learned by doing you know the vast
majority of people who right now have a
job any job outside of science and
medicine almost everything they're doing
right now I mean including you if you're
listening to this and you have a job and
that is not that it's not in the science
and medicine field most likely if you
think about it everything you do in your
job you learned how to do in the job
itself or these were skills that you
brought in on your own that had nothing
to do with schooling whatsoever that's
how most jobs are learned they're
learned by doing now it's not as though
one excuse you here is while companies
are saving money on having to try train
new hires by requiring the college
degree and so this is about saving money
that's not the case the companies still
have to train the college graduates you
know these employers are discovering to
their shock somehow that you know when
it when someone comes in at the age of
23 and they've been in a classroom their
whole life and haven't done anything you
still have to train
just as much as you would have to train
someone without a college degree so
what's the point of the degree it serves
no purpose no function now it might be
argued that employers look for the
degree because even if the degree is in
dance theory or comparative religion it
at least proves that the applicant is
competent and hard-working and so on
well you know I would like to see some
reach research supporting that
assumption because I don't believe it I
see no reason to conclude that college
grads are any smarter any more competent
any harder working than non college
grads I understand that that's maybe the
assumption that employers are making I'm
saying it's a bad assumption I'm saying
it's an assumption based on nothing in
fact I would wager that the scales
probably tipped the other way because a
23 year old who's been working and
supporting himself since the age of 18
has already demonstrated at a minimum
that he has the basic life skills
necessary to be a functioning adult
Society there are many college grads who
don't even have that because if you
graduate college with it with it with a
bachelor's degree
congratulations not taking anything away
from you but it doesn't prove that you
know how to do anything doesn't prove
you have any skills at all it doesn't
prove that you're a functioning adult
doesn't really prove anything you know
what it proves in and of itself in and
of itself all the degree if you tell me
if the only information I have about
someone is they have a college degree
you tell me that you know Bob Smith has
a college degree what does that tell you
about Bob Smith but the only thing it
tells you is that he either had the
money to get a college education or he
was willing to take on the debt that's
the only thing it tells you now it might
be that that Bob Smith is a brilliant
guy a hard worker so on and so forth
what I'm saying though is that the fact
of the degree doesn't tell you that you
got to look deeper into who Bob Smith is
but if we're looking deeper and who
people are then why can't you do that
with non college grads
we all know the truth I think employers
demand the high-priced degrees for
entry-level positions
entry-level positions that in many cases
a moderately intelligent monkey could
learn in less than a week the reason why
they they require it is that it's it's
just out of laziness the degree
requirement is a way to call the heard
of applicants to widdle things down a
little bit making it easier to sift
through it's just a you know it's all
it's just it's just sort of you got a
stack of a hundred applications or
resumes and you just you toss 50 of them
out just because it's hard to go through
a hundred you rather go through fifty
and and that's basically the reason
that's why these these employers do it
if qualified applicants are tossed to
the side that's a sacrifice the employer
is willing to make for the sake of
streamlining the process but if it
wasn't for the demands of these lazy the
arbitrary demands of these lazy HR
departments who don't feel like doing
their jobs don't feel like actually
evaluating applicants based on the
individual merits of the people who are
coming in for the job if it wasn't for
that kids out of high school may not
feel the need to take on crushing debt
just to obtain a piece of paper that may
only ever function as a symbolic calling
card that prevents their resume from
automatically being thrown in the trash
it's crazy it's crazy that we that we
tolerate this as a society that we just
take it for granted that this is the way
it is perhaps the companies that
unjustly discriminated against competent
workers who lack a piece of paper should
finally start absorbing some of the
scorn and the blame that we directed
everybody except them now yes they have
every right to come up with whatever
unnecessary and expensive job
requirements they want but but they
deserve to be named and shamed for it
they should have to explain you know
these companies that are requiring
degrees for jobs that will 100% be
learned on the job regardless they
should have to explain why they're doing
that they should have to give us a good
reason I don't think they can
they can't it's pure laziness and as I
said we accept it because that's just
the way it is we say that's the way it's
always been
that's like it's not the way it's always
been this is a very new thing that we've
decided it's very new very recent in
modern history we've decided that if you
want to get a basic job that that anyone
could do you need you first need you
know four years at a university and you
need to spend ninety thousand dollars on
a degree that's that's it's it's not
always been this way there's no reason
why it needs to be this way we've just
decided that it will be and I
we should probably make other decisions
okay now I want to give a shout out to
all of our daily wire members you guys
are the ones that keep us in business
here we love making content that matters
and while we're on the front lines of
the culture war we know that we can't do
it without your support so if you're
still skeptical about joining the daily
wire a reader's pass is a great way to
start and it's a great value readers
pass will enable news junkies to read
our articles ad-free including op-eds
from ben shapiro which are exclusive to
daily wire Members Only you get access
to our mobile app which has really
become popular with all of our members
and you can read all of our stories on
mobile and you also receive push
notifications for breaking news special
content it's perfect for when you want
to stay up to date on the go this
Membership tier is already at a bargain
at $3 a month it's hard to get cheaper
than that but it just did get cheaper
than that right now we're offering one
month at $0.99 that's mobile ad free
access to all of our daily Wired news
exclusive op-eds from ben shapiro
breaking news and updates on our mobile
app and all for the low price of one
dollar less than a dollar so give it a
shot it's worth it and now it's time for
our daily cancellation and today I'm
afraid that I have to cancel someone and
I have to cancel my self I am cancelled
and I wish I didn't have to be cancelled
especially in the day that my book comes
out not not if not a very advantageous
time but I have no choice there's of
course a list of reasons 5 light-years
long for why I should be cancelled and I
have been canceled time and time again
the reason this time though is that this
weekend for the second time in as many
weeks I managed to dump a whole cup of
coffee in a Starbucks a whole venti cup
of coffee dumped on the ground
splattered everywhere everywhere if you
ever if you've ever spilled something in
public you know that somehow it manages
its like the defies the laws of physics
and you dump it and in 100 feet away
there's there's there splatter still so
it's that's what I did
and in fact I have this is gonna sound
like an exaggeration but it's really not
I have now spilled an entire cup of
coffee in a Starbucks five times in the
last year five times this is my fifth
time doing it all in different locations
I'm like a terrorist on on a spilling
spree all across the the eastern
seaboard now I'm not doing it on purpose
I am just a very clumsy and awkward
person and I have long limbs that I
can't control so I'm when I walk I'm
just flailing all over the place
knocking things over everywhere I go I'm
look at drunken Gumby basically
barreling around although I have to say
that Starbucks and fairness to me
Starbucks should be partially canceled
as well this is partially their fault
because part of the problem is yes I'm a
bumbling oaf that's true but their
tables are so small so I'm sitting at
their thumbtack sized table and I've got
my my laptop and I got the cup of coffee
I move my laptop slightly cut knock
services happened five times already the
last year and then there's the awkward
thing of I have to go to the counter and
tell them that I spilled something and
then I always offer to clean it but it's
more symbolic because I know that they
can't accept my offer so they have to
send the girl out with the mop and then
there's even more awkward thing where I
have to ask for another coffee because I
still need my coffee let's be real here
and then as the girl is mopping it up I
just slink out the other door and
disappear into the fog never to be seen
again though nothing could be worse and
that was bad enough nothing can be worse
than the time and this happened in the
past year also the time when I dropped a
bottle of red wine in the grocery store
as I was I was going up to pay for it I
dropped it red wine everywhere I mean
everywhere and the guy came up the
employee came up and and he saw it and
these were his exact words he said oh my
god just like that you never want that
reaction when you're out in public from
him from anybody for any reason and I
you know I tried to I admit I tried to
pass the buck a little bit I said yeah
you know I I don't know what I don't
know what happened I think the glass in
your wine bottles is kind of weak you
guys have a weak glass problem I you
should probably look into that I don't
know what you know someone could get
hurt I don't know well I don't know how
this happened it wasn't it's not me I
mean it just happened
and then again I left and I never I
never returned to the places where I
spill things at this point my options of
places where I can go has been severely
limited so that's why I unfortunately
have to be canceled yeah I don't accept
myself from the cancelling and I never
would do that but I I forge on ahead
anyway in spite of being cancelled all
right let's go to emails we read a few
emails now this is a Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
is the email address this is from
Michael says hey Matt as a former
infantry marine with two deployments to
the Middle East
I appreciate your commenting on that
story that the Commandant of the Corps
says that he has new priorities it's
beyond dumb it is going to make the
Corps more combat ineffective anyway
thanks for throwing that in there notice
you haven't been answering questions on
the show recently but I'll ask a
question anyway when you rise to your
rightful place as the supreme tyrannical
dictator will you allow the Marines and
other services to grow beards while
serving thanks man love the show Michael
not only will I allow the Marines to
grow beards but I will require it I
think this should be a requirement I
believe that the prohibition of beards
in the military is one of the great
moral outrages that we currently face as
a society I also think it puts lives at
risk because everybody knows that men
become more it becomes stronger and more
resilient as they grow their facial hair
and so I think look you go back to the
Civil War and there were glorious facial
hair styles on display in fact back in
those days it was understood that one of
the primary roles of the military was to
promote facial hair and modeled new
facial hair styles and I would like to
get back to that point so yes absolutely
this is from Matt says Matt as a fellow
Matt I have to say that you missed the
mark on today's show when you stated
that 10 years from now nearly all
leftists will be arguing in favor of
pedophilia although the leftists are
absurdly arguing that children can
choose their own gender I highly doubt
that even a significant portion of
leftist will actually advocate
pedophilia yes you could argue that if a
5 year old child has the mental and
emotional capacity to choose his or her
gender than the natural extension of
this is that
they must have enough maturity to
consent to sexual activity however I
just don't buy it there is no way that
our society will allow things to
progress that far although as I typed
this I realized that in 2010 I would
have stated that 10 years from then
there is no way our society will be
advocating that 5 year old boys could
decide that they're actually 5 year old
girls who knows maybe they are that
crazy well Matt you said yourself 10
years ago you could not have possibly
imagined or predicted that 10 years in
the future in 2020 all leftists in the
country all of them including you know
in the mainstream with Democrats
presidential candidates would be saying
that three year old boys can choose to
become girls you would not have
predicted that and if somebody had
predicted that to you 10 years ago you
would have thought they were crazy and
so that should be enough reason to give
you pause when I talk about this
you know you would have reacted 10 years
ago to that the way you're reacting now
when I talk about how 10 years in the
future
the left's gonna be advocating for
pedophilia there's a logical progression
here I'm not issuing some kind of
prophecy based on a vision of the future
I had in a dream that's not what's
happening here I'm saying there's a
logical conclusion if children have the
emotional and psychological capacity to
decide to change their gender if they
have this capacity even as toddlers and
if their decision should be respected so
much and trusted so much that we even
give them drugs to chemically castrate
them to aid them in their transformation
into girls then it's not a far leap to
say that they have the mental and
emotional capacity to consent to sex if
they can consent to a sex change then
why not a sex act so yes 10 years from
now we will be told that we need to
respect the lifestyle choices of adults
who have sex with children that's what
we're gonna be told we're gonna be told
that children are perfectly able to
consent and that if they want to be in
these relationships we should respect it
and it's bigotry for us to do otherwise
that's where we're headed
and unless unless we as a culture revolt
against this this this nonsense and put
a stop to it but if we let it continue
on the path that's going that's where it
goes finally is from Connor says Matt
original about blaming employee
employers for the debt problem you sound
like a socialist yourself
first of all employers have the right to
make these decisions what happened to
the right of business owners second it
is perfectly valid for them to focus on
college graduates they will know that
college graduates at least have basic
literacy and are capable of completing
tasks your rant was silly
well Connor I never said that employers
don't have the right okay so I'm talking
about what is the right thing to do I'm
not talking about what we have the right
to do is a two different concepts so
that's completely irrelevant second I
need a citation needed okay you say that
college graduates are gonna be better
able to complete tasks and they have
basic literacy well as far as basic
literacy you can easily tell that you
don't need a college degree to tell us
someone's basically basically literate
just by interviewing them and by looking
at their resume that should be enough to
tell you and and you know if you need
how about adding an additional step an
additional test you could you could even
just have a brief questionnaire with
essay style answers talking about why
you know asking applicants to explain
why they want the job or while though
why they're they'd be fitted best suited
for the job and just based on that you
you can tell that they're literate or
not and you can tell a lot about their
intelligence as far as being able to
complete tasks well call me crazy but if
somebody has a work experience if
they've been at a job especially a
related job for a number of years that
tells me they can complete tasks they
could do things it tells me tells me
more than a degree does you know you've
got two candidates one has been in
college the last four years the other
has been working in the working world
you're telling me that the former the
college grad has better proven his
ability to work to do things to complete
things how so you know I mean if the
other guy even if the other guys been at
McDonald's for the last four years
well that tells me that he's reliable he
gets up and he comes to work he's
trainable he's teachable there's a
number of things you can tell right away
and you can also call up his boss and
ask him so the point is for most of
these jobs there's just no good reason
to rule out non college grads
plenty of them could be better suited
could be better workers than college
graduates
the only reason they ruled out for the
job is as I said laziness and I don't
think that's right I don't think that's
I don't think that's enough of a reason
I don't I don't think the the need that
employers have this to streamline a
process and not put any effort into it I
don't think that's a good enough reason
to justify 1.5 trillion dollars in
student debt that's my point and we will
leave it there again my book Church of
cowards is out now please go buy it and
I will talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there